in this capsule we will be reducing the
concept of decision making process
to the lion then in this part of the court
we will firstly obviously define this
What is a decision process?
come back this will get us to define the
notions of plans or policies as well
than the value of a plan or a
policy
we will see two algorithms value
creation is not also region for this
we're going to say we're going to solve them
decision process mark well
that is, solving problems
that can be modeled using a
audi brand decision process then
the decision process mark comes
will be useful in the context of a
agent youtu be based on remember
that a useful agent tibet is an agent
who can leave from Sancerre to capture
information on its environment
from that will try to put to
day his estimate of the state of
the environment then given its
knowledge about how the world
evolves then what are the
consequences of his actions will try
to maximize internal utility in order to
determine which of the head action that
takes the rex that will trigger so a
some way of interacting so
certain actions undertake on his
environment and with the processes of
marco decision comes so these are some
it's a mathematical tool for
model that kind of behavior this
kind of environment there we want to take
actions is among other things that me
allow to incorporate the fact that
maybe we do not know exactly
what will be the hurdles the effects of
our actions maybe we have to
uncertainty about the effect of
our actions
which will necessarily reduce a
uncertainty about on the state of our
environment maybe too much because
that information capture through our
censors in relation to our honor is going
to be in fact the raw information and is
so at any time our our
estimate of the state of the environment
will have associated with her some
uncertainty and so with the processes
decision marco well we are able
to handle that uncertainty there for
take actions that are rational
but an example of the kind of decisions
that we would like to be able to model in a
context where there is uncertainty but
I recognize the actions have been
handsomely the action of al she is to
doors and minutes before departure from
the plane
and here I want to know if action in
question would arrive on time
well there are several problems there are
the uncertainty of the kind after eating a
observe partial ability of my
environment ie the
road conditions
it's basically a piece of information
be partial to noise t2 real
road conditions they go a little a
certain delay between the moment
I learn that traffic that is the
when there is indeed traffic
so that's related to things like
gross censors and he also goes from
the uncertainty in the facts of my
actions so even though I'm driving well
my car it may be that I have a
puncture that there is a breakdown that have
nothing to see that my way driving but
more about car wear by
example laid bare and generally speaking
is going to be a pretty complex environment
to model and with the processes of
decision mark at the lion will do
some assumptions that will simplify
the simplified model our modeling
of the environment that will allow us
still to model it so
satisfactory to take good
decisions to solve problems
interesting
so maybe another example of
problems a little more detail so
imagine that we have a robot that
represented by the little circle here and that
the robot can move on a 20
grill or cat
squares like that corresponds to a
possible position in the grid is
long several pieces are listed
here and my robot can take on everything
moment four actions is winter is
west south or north east
the robot a goal ie to get
make it here and that it's going to be presented
that a utility function that represents
the degree of desirability of the different
four times when we bend gray +1
for the state of a robot that lies
in a box in this region 6.06 is
found nowhere else except at
some places like that that could
correspond to boxes him and
obstacles that we would like the robot
is fast by someone would have a degree
of negative desirability and the in this
this case have taken magic that there is
indeed uncertain effects to
our actions to know that if I determine
that I will go I want the robot
arrives to the south maybe with 5
taking away two parts I'm going
actually move to the box in
underneath but with a heart of
probabilities I go below but
left so south west or down
go right or south
is that so it would allow
represent the fact that a real robot is
still limited in his way of
move to make some mistakes and
so we'll see that this kind of notions
we'll be able to incorporate it into a
mark decision process comes back via
probabilities